hi there steve kaufman here again uh in
this fourth
in this series of uh
steve summer sessions where i ask you to
send in your questions
uh about language learning or about link
or
and also i should add in any language
that i can answer i'm quite happy to
answer questions in languages
other than english as long as i speak
them
the questions i've asked you to submit
them through twitter
at hashtags ask steve
now today i want to answer some
questions that i've received that relate
to fluency
questions such as
what is fluency how do you achieve
fluency how do you achieve fluency in
the country where the language is spoken
not in the country where the language is
spoken and so forth okay
my definition of fluency is
it's a bit like um
you know are you fit
okay you don't have to be a bodybuilder
you don't have to be a marathon runner
in order to be fit
uh
i think fluency is a matter of feeling
comfortable in the language
comfortable that you understand most
situations comfortable that you can
basically express yourself in most
situations but it doesn't mean that
you're perfect it doesn't mean that your
accent is
you know
easily mistaken for a native speaker
it means that you make grammatical
mistakes it means that you occasionally
can't find the right word uh it means
that you may very well have a pronounced
accent
you know my father who was born in
czechoslovakia
he had a
very identical
accent for
most of the 30 years that he lived in
canada but he was absolutely fluent in
english did business in english and we
have all met people who are very fluent
in english and who have certain turns of
phrase that are still
more or less you know reflect their
uh country of origin
uh or who have accents and who make
mistakes so fluent means to be
comfortable in the language
and so in my own case so then the next
question is can you become fluent
if you don't live in the country
where the language is spoken and of
course the answer is yes
i was on a speaking tour in china about
eight years ago
and i spoke to students at various
universities there including the um i
think it was called the beijing y yes
yeah yeah
and uh also in uh
near shanghai the
uh hua dong shira fandasia or something
or in jejung i think it was the young
dasia in hungary
and i met all kinds of students who were
excellent in english japanese french and
so forth so these were obviously
students who had dedicated themselves to
learning the language so i think it is
possible but it takes an awful lot of
work to to achieve real fluency not in
the country where the language is spoken
uh it's a lot easier to do in the
language in the country the language is
spoken but being in the country where
the language is spoken doesn't ensure
that you're going to become fluent i
lived in japan for nine years i learned
japanese most foreigners there didn't
bother or maybe they tried but they
didn't succeed
you know we know lots of immigrants in
different countries who lived there for
20 or 30 years and never learned to
speak the language properly
so
how do you become fluent all right i
believe that it takes a lot of work
regardless where you are it takes a lot
of the same kinds of things that i talk
about all the time a lot of time with
the language a positive attitude towards
the language wanting to learn the
language liking the language uh
in my case a lot of input type
activities a lot of listening and
reading
using things that are of interest to me
building up my
basic comprehension abilities and my
vocabulary so that you build up your
potential to become fluent however to be
genuinely fluent
uh and remember this means to be
comfortable in the language i'll just
digress for a second every so often i'll
put up a video in some language and
people say well you're no good you make
mistakes and and someone said to be
really fluent in a language you have to
be able to
uh say things like
how do i time my shoelaces i can't
remember there's a long list i think it
was a commenter here at youtube
of very obscure things that a native
speaker can say i know how to say time
my shoelaces in english but i don't
necessarily know how to say that in
other languages that i speak quite well
it doesn't come up if it doesn't come up
very often you're not going to be used
to saying it you can't be you're not
going to go and study a whole bunch of
possible obscure scenarios you learn
basic vocabulary through following your
interests and the first or second time i
have to express myself on how to tie my
shoelaces i'll know how to tie my
shoelaces it's not important
fluency is just being comfortable in
most situations
so to become comfortable in most
situations i believe eventually you have
to speak and you have to speak a lot
because fluency implies not only that
you understand and you can read fluency
implies that you can express yourself
not necessarily in writing because not
every situation requires writing and
there's lots of people who are very
fluent
uh in languages that you know where
they don't write i don't know uh in
i i added that in ethiopia people are
quite multilingual but i'm sure they
don't write in all the different
languages that they speak so writing to
my mind is not a condition for fluency
uh
it may be a
a skill that one should train and it may
be required for certain jobs but it's
not an absolute condition of fluency but
speaking comfortably is so in order to
speak comfortably you have to speak a
lot it's difficult to create a situation
where you speak a lot if you're away
from the country where the language is
spoken those students in china i'm sure
they have lots of opportunity to
practice their language they were fully
dedicated to the task but for the
average learner like me who puts in an
hour to a day i can't simply suspend my
normal professional and social
activities in order to look for romanian
speakers or korean speakers and
socialize with them all the time it's
just not practical
so
but eventually if you want to become
fluent you have to expo you have to
speak a lot okay so what does that mean
if i summarize it means that uh
you know you you should invest a lot of
time and effort into building up your
passive capacity in the language which i
have done in say 13 languages
but if i look at the languages that i'm
most fluent in
english obviously french and japanese
those are the languages where i have
lived
in the country where the language is
spoken and so i am much more fluent in
those than any others
the next on my list is mandarin because
i studied it full time like those
students in china i was at it seven
eight hours a day but i lived in hong
kong which is not a mandarin speaking
environment so i didn't you know have
that chance to bring it up to the same
level as my japanese
however i have a very good potential
level in mandarin
i still call myself fluent although i'm
not as good as in japanese but if i were
to live in china for three months
i have a sufficient
grounding through my massive input
activities that i could bring myself up
to quite a high level now next on my
list let's say is spanish i have never
lived in a spanish-speaking country i
have spent at most one or two weeks in a
spanish-speaking country on a number of
different occasions when i'm there my
spanish improves when i go away and i
don't speak so often my spanish
basically
goes down a notch although the potential
is still there and then as you go on to
my languages you know german swedish
italian russian czech i feel that in all
of them including romanian
uh where i just visited for three four
days if i had the opportunity to live
there for let's say three months
in any of those countries russia
czech republic and so forth italy
that i could bring my language ability
way up because i would be speaking all
the time so
uh when we talk about fluency i don't
think it's possible even for luca and
and richard simcott who are outstanding
polyglots they can't have
all of their languages you know totally
fine tuned so that at the drop of the
hat of a hat they can just
wow just completely
feel comfortable in the language they
may have a handful of languages where
they are very good and comfortable
easily but then others where they are
potentially fluent and i would still
call them fluent
but
it would take a week two weeks in the
country to really be
comfortable
so
you know
how do you get the fluency it's the same
as how you learn languages in my opinion
a lot of input activities following your
interest building up your vocabulary but
eventually a lot of speaking
a lot of speaking is more easily done
in the country where the language is
spoken but even if you are in the
country where the language is spoken if
all you do is speak
if you don't put that effort into
increasing your vocabulary broadening
the range of your comprehension then
you'll be like these immigrants who can
speak at a certain level but never
really get beyond that level so even in
the country where the language is spoken
you have to put that effort into your
input activities
developing that ability to notice the
language the pronunciation the
structures you have to put the effort in
if you're not in that country where the
language is spoken you would have to put
in a lot of time
uh not only in input but eventually in
talking to people via skype or otherwise
in order to achieve
fluency but the final word is that
fluency
is not
equivalent to being perfect you don't
have to speak with no noticeable accent
you don't have to speak with no mistakes
you don't have to be able to express
yourself on every single
conceivable situation including how to
tie your shoelaces
there will be situations where you don't
understand
you may be fluent and still miss some
things while watching a movie you can
still be fluent so that's my definition
of fluency and that i hope i've touched
on some of the other questions that
related to how do we achieve fluency and
how do we achieve fluency both in the
country where the language is spoken and
away from the country where the language
is spoken so thank you very much
and i look forward to your questions and
comments bye for now